femme vie liberté scan se manifestants
atterrant il crie aussi Massa Amini un
nom devenu depuis trois jours le cri de
ralliement des Iraniens qui réclament
plus de liberté la jeune femme de 22 ans
est décédée en prison vendredi quelques
jours après avoir été arrêté à Téhéran
sous prétexte qu'elle ne portait pas son
hijab correctement
je me pose vigoureusement à ces méthodes
si cette étudiant on ne peut pas imposer
une pratique culturelle par la force les
circonstances de la mort sont suspectes
des groupes de défense des droits en
Iran affirment que Massa a probablement
été battu et torturé à mort ce que ni
toujours les autorités iraniennes
la police de la moralité n'a pas les
moyens de frapper des inculpés les
agents n'ont pas de bâton mais les
Iraniens ne semble pas croire ce démenti
sans doute lorsque la torture est
commune dans les prisons du pays
elle assassin de ma soeur Chris et ses
hommes qui dénonce les violences contre
les femmes en Iran
[Applaudissements]
des manifestations ont eu lieu un peu
partout au pays des hommes et des femmes
de tous âges de tous les milieux ont
bravé l'oppression du régime ça a monté
une vague de protestation
inimaginables aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment
la chair de poule de voir que plus d'une
centaine de villes en Iran il y a des
manifestations il a eu ma chou-fhabilité
contre le régime des ayatollas pendant
10 ans avant de fuir l'Iran quand son
mari a été torturé en prison la mort de
Massa la bouleversée je pensais que ça
aurait pu être ma fille parce que
pendant la Révolution moi aussi avec mes
enfants et nous étions dans la rue et
vous savez c'est depuis
79 que les femmes se battent trois
semaines après la révolution on s'est
battu le 8 mars contre le régime
islamique et depuis ça continue et les
femmes ont continué avec beaucoup de
misères des arrestations des
emprisonnements
la force des manifestations fenêtres
l'espoir que la mort de la jeune Massa
aussi horrible soit-elle puisse
provoquer les changements réclamés par
de plus en plus d'Iraniens si sa mort
peut apporter une ouverture de la
société vers un changement profond dans
la en Iran ça va être en tout cas ça on
peut la liberté très cher vous le savez
dans ce pays là ici Sophie Langlois
Radio-Canada Montréal